so good afternoon everyone so can you
hear can you all hear me the back okay
cool so how many of you like machine
learning right how many of yous
scikit-learn Python okay how many of you
have used h2o okay cool it is h2o for
beginners so I will type with some
really extreme for example the main
objective of this workshop is to get you
started so we're not going to know we're
very deep details of how to use x0 for
once features but one we get you just
started so getting a dataset into x0 try
to do some X you learning from that and
this is to get you started so as I said
before if you want to download all the
materials this is the address to the
tunnel tutorial materials so let's go
for the agenda so I've been here three
times I've been here in Berlin three
times so every time the weather was
really nice except yesterday and today
so luckily I'm here so so let's go for
this tutorial so first of all I want to
give you a really quick introductions of
the company NMC eternal name platform
that we have it's also called h2o and
then we move on to the hands on the
tutorials that you have to order given
up box and other data within that key
hub repository so the first half it's
only for beginners so it's mainly about
the basic usage of h2o in Python and
then we will have a maybe a five minutes
topic and after that I'll go on to more
a bit more advanced feature of h2o it's
as if I'm trying to use h2o for data
mining competitions so a little bit
information about myself so you can see
that I wasn't a computer scientist or
data scientist by training so I've been
in the civil engineering industry for 10
years so somehow discover h2o about
three years ago and then a few things
after that become a data scientist so
this could be one of the reasons that
you may want to try h2o today because
it's easy to use you have you to know
lower barrier of machine learning so you
can try to some really advanced stuff
but with simple API T in Python and in
other interface so so after my know
civil engineering journey so I went to
become a
get a scientist I work for Virgin Media
a telecom in UK and terminal design labs
another community in us before I joined
hto about around February last year this
is how I met h2o so I went to a
conference back in 2014 the use out
conference in UCLA so so I heard about
this communica h2o so that at that
moment I thought it could be someone
crazy or someone really smart so to use
h2o as the name so I gave it a try and I
never regret so I went on to world blog
post / a blog post about how to use XTO
domino and now to do a data mining
conditions they call cargo platform and
that's how I join h2o ok so let's talk
about h2o a ISO xji is the name of the
company so we are a small a young
company so we are talking about in 2011
and then we get about 70 people at the
moment so the high cadre is based in
California is waiting man here in
California so I'm one of the two guys
based in UK and then we from 2014 when I
first discover h2o I think they kept the
momentum in terms of getting more users
and more customer and you can see that
out there many of the top company in us
they're using HT 2 and these are some
phrases that in hto so we can see that
we have a real good balance between a
male and female so which are get to
50/50 in next row and that's me stand
there and we are so lucky to have a free
legendary professor from Stanford as a
writer because we implement some of our
algorithms from scratch in Java so we
need someone as experienced a stem to
gas through a journey so this is how
they work in a hacker so this in the
middle is a no and I can do it our CTO
and then professor around him just to
try to improve some of the algorithms in
h2o
oh by the way this is more interactive
section so at any time if you want to
ask question just please raise your hand
and now we try we put your questions ok
this tutorial is mainly about h2o
machine learning platform so what we do
have other products like deep water
which is our GPU deep learning
sparkling water is about integration
with spark and steam each other surface
that we can have you deploy a model but
this tutorial today is mainly about XTO
platform ok so let's talk about our
platform before I move on to the the
actual details I want to give you some
reasons while you won't try XTO right by
doing this workshop or after this
workshop so I'm going to use a bench map
from Mozilla Parker so he's not working
for h2o is a scientist in LA so he did a
benchmark using different implementation
of GBM of gradient boosting machines in
our in Python in a spark ml lib in h2o
and in extra boost so what I found is
that one of the key point he found is
that when you have regulator so it turns
from 10,000 little pond or rose to 10
million h2o is the fastest when you have
spectators and we didn't sacrifice the
performance so in this case we're using
a you see the area on the curve at the
metric to measure the performance so we
didn't sacrifice the performance for
speed so this is one of the reason why
you may want to try hto Piketty simply
high-performance capable and powerful in
in a ready when you compared to other
implementations of the same algorithms
so what is h2o so this is a really high
level architecture of X tone so you can
see that from left hand side you have
different connectors to database or
other files so today we will start with
a Toyota set in CSV but if you are
feeling comfortable with XTO in the
future you can move on to spark a tube
or a database in your company so there
are many ways to connect your data to
h2o so in the middle you can see that
the yellow rectangle in the middle is
the heart of h2o so already from in XTO
in sweden in java so it is for
high-performance and scalable
algorithm in the in a compute engine so
it is a machine learning platform so we
can expect it to many common tasks that
you would do for machine learning so
including importing data look at that
data training models or other supervised
or unsupervised model export the model
and make some prediction so this is the
platform a generic platform which in any
platform that you can do with many
different current problems and because
we know that not everyone like to use
Java so how many of you use Java for
work okay so not too many of you use
Java so we will add this into the
problem so we want to create different
interface even API is for different
users so people can use today we're
using Python or you can use out in the
future you can use even the web
interface that I will so later on to use
h0 with different kind of interface and
some people can stop right there if so
if you have a model within Python you
can stop there but some people like to
bring it to productions and that's why
we have the last part here so we can
export the hcto model at a single Java
file oh and then that file you can put
it into a different machines for scoring
or for now in a different PI nine so
that's what we're trying to focus today
is one of the interface of XTO in python
before we do that i want to show you
quickly so you know this is the web
interface of actually also people so
maybe your Kali or your your friends
they may not like to use Python they
will not use any programming language
you can give them give them this
interface using just a web browser and
to use that to interact with XTO so we
can still do most of the features to use
model features of XTO with the web
browser that including your data pure
model and export the model and we'll
make some predictions but we are
focusing on the use case in python today
and just a bit more about the algorithm
itself so everything is written in the
mind of the tributed a manner so we
everything that you do today may be on
your single machines or your laptop
today but if you want to use h2o with
multiple custom multiple machine
multiple nodes it is the same
same time of cook that the same the same
thing that you did today on your laptop
when you move on to a bigger cluster or
with more CPU power you automatically
distributed across all CPU resource that
you are signed to hto clusters that's
ultimately done for all users so you do
not have to think about how to optimize
that paralyzation for different
structure it will just do it for you
okay so that's a really quick
introduction of htall company and actual
platform so now we just move on to the
hands-on tutorials
it's any questions before I move on to
this tutorial is that we wasn't happy
have you all got the materials on your
laptop so I won't ask you to run the the
coke today and in real time because I
have prepare order jupiter dropbox on
github repository or on that USB stick
so we can just look at the result and
look at how i explained in the logic and
to you
so the key objectives of this workshop
today is to get you started with x2 so I
want you to have you how to start the
hto cluster with python I want to show
you how to import it the same in
different ways so we can use a local CSV
file you can use something from Internet
I want to show you how to perform some
basic ETFs or some basic data
transformations and how to export it in
Python I want to show you the basic API
to training regression model and
classification models these are the two
way command coming to us in machine
learning and after that that's the basic
one so after that I want to show you how
to evaluate the model performance and
how to you can tune it to improve the
performance of different algorithms and
at the end I want to show you how to use
one of the key features in next door to
stack the model together and this is one
of the really and a key trick to improve
your performance for telephoning
competitions like toggle I also appear
free how you can deploy hto in the cloud
so because hto is written in java you
can just de point on any machine with
java 1.7 or Oracle 1.7 or open JDK okay
so again this is the link for tutorial
let me just show you the real thing in
the web browser
so see that if you go to this repository
you can see the actual tutorial and an
introduction to machine learning there
are lots of Jupiter notebook here for
you can see the pipe one on the top they
are the example in Python but if you are
also interested in using h2o with our
you can see that the bottom few ones are
written in now so we start with the
first one the first one is just showing
you how to initiate a Kuster of XTO and
then import some data into it so I must
go back to them so if if you are on
github repository now you can click on
the first one so it is 0-1 oh I don't
have connection I'll just go for the
slide from here sign ok
oh of course one more thing how many of
you have info HDL before this session
okay one two three
but don't worry about it so it's not
that typical doing so HCl so all the
instructions are online so if you go to
a HT ODI forward slash panel then you
can find the information about how to
dunno XTO and install it in Python so
basically it's like this if you can see
maybe it's not that clear but it's
basically it's just a few dependency in
Python and then you insert piping meal
in your Python explosions it's nothing
really complicated to install X 0 you
can think about hto as a module for your
Python module on your computer so
assuming that you have h to install then
we can move on to the actual work so you
don't have to do anything right now you
just have to look at the the tube is a
notebook on your laptop and I'll just go
for the key step and explain to you the
logic behind different steps so the
first part is to start and connect you
XTO Kuster the reason why is that our
computation is done in Java so when you
execute the code in Python it's not
using Python to do the computations it's
using Java to do the hard work and
that's why we need to initiate a custard
in terms of a Java Virtual Machine or
JVM so that's the command so when you
have actual install you just called
module just import the module as excuse
so import h2o first so the second
command is x2 odo ini TSO initiate a
cluster so the are given in that is n
fat so number of virtual virtual call I
can say virtual course or maybe if you
have a control computer you may have a
virtual call so if you put on the lumber
the actual number in there may be four
five six
it will then allocate that resource to
the actual cluster but if you don't know
how much how many we also call you have
on that machines you can use Swedish -
one much one is like an automatic
detection so we just go for you know
your systems back and look at how many
virtual calls that you have on the
computer then we use everything so once
you have that then you will see
something that is maybe you can't see
quickly but this is like an information
of the JV
am the java virtual machines so you can
see how much memory is allocated to that
JVM how many virtual Co is allocated to
that JVM and to secure a picture and you
can also see the IP address so that IP
address and the port number is all you
need to connect to the akio cluster or
using using web browser or using our
Python I guess ok so far yeah so this is
just to cut a cut on your laptop so we
are still doing the things in the same
low pops so the next step so once you
have the cutter in the memory next thing
you can do is to import some data so
also use free ways to import data from a
CSV file so the first way is the most
easiest way is that you have two CSV
file on your hard drive or somewhere on
your level type so you know the exact
tracks of that file so what you need to
do in h0 is using the h2o doc
import underscore CSV and then you point
to the path of the file so in this case
I have this wine quality CSV in here you
can find in the github repository and
after that you can just do the same
thing that you would do in Python you
can look at the first few rows using dot
hat command and it will show you the
first few first five rows of potater as
you can see it here so but sometimes you
want to have some data store on the
internet and you just just want to
download that at least on the web so you
can do the same thing you can use the
same command so XTO on top import files
but then this time you you provide the
food at you as the full URLs of test
files online and just we just do the
same thing it's just another thing and
then import it into CS and going into
the actual cluster and again you can do
the head so we can look at the first few
rows and sometimes this is a when you do
data munging in Python first so you want
to use panda so that you have a lot of
procedures lower pylons to clean data to
transform later to create different
features and once you're happy with the
final data frame in pandas you can use
h2o you can use a command h2o to convert
that panel to the frame into Java into
hto data frame in Java so the command is
if you see in the bottom half there it's
the XTO top actual actual frame so that
is to to compare to convert anything in
panda to the frame into the extra
cluster which is in Java so that is the
way that you can convert anything from
pandas to XTO the defame okay I'll be
okay so far yeah so that's some basic
way to import data set so now we have
the way to import it so we can now do
some exploration or transform some old
data so we are going to move on to the
next jupiter notebook so if we go to the
PI and let's go 0 to the data annotation
notebook so we are going to discuss how
to some some ways to export or the
transformer data once you have imported
into h2o
so first of all I'm going to use the
classic Titanic data set so it is a
seriously again in the same github
repository so when you have stat there
you can just do ahead and okay to some
of the records here you can see that so
some information about the passenger on
that on Titanic and whether they
survived or not
so first of all we can do some basic
things you look at the the data so if
you can see that from this table the
second column for the left-hand side
above survives so it's always 0 and 1 so
it is in h2o as integer but we we know
that so with our pivot experience you
know that this is like a binary
classification so it's yes or no but
actually XTO doesn't know that so in
order to do that we have to tell X show
that this is actually a categorical
label instead of integer so first of all
we want to do a histogram and okay
whether it's just only two units ready
so we do the dog piss and then blanket
and I can see that it is only two unit
values in that column you can also use
the count
functions or the table functioning in
Python to look at how many counts of
each day of each class so for 0.5 meters
for denying etc etcetera
so we know that there are only two
unique values so now we can tell x2
we can change it to form an integer to
calculate value the way to do it in xgo
is to use the dock as factor and blanket
so this way XTO we know that this column
here the wife is not integers
it's a categorical value so when you do
the classification you know that this is
a binary classification instead of other
questions it's just saying that if you
can do that summary as well so for for
other things in and Axios at the same
you can do it summary and they will give
you some information about vibrator the
type of theta the missing values Max and
min exactly cetera
so this time you can see that it becomes
Elam Elam is the type of categorical
value in Java and that's why they use it
in here is for Iran okay so similarly we
can do the histogram on a different
column so this time I want to look at
the cost to put in your class in there
so again we can see that there are only
three different variables in there's a
one to a fee you can also use a table to
do the same thing let's look at the con
of that so there's some basic stuff to
look at the data if you want okay so far
yep okay so now we look at some data set
so we can move on to the next step I
want to show you how to use h2o in
Python to train the requestion model it
is some of the algorithm to set up the
sum of algorithm that we have and éxito
so on let's focus on left-hand side it's
a supervised learning problem because we
have the label where the final answer
which spawns in antennae set so we want
to use the supervised learning algorithm
in this case to be requesting model so
we have body commands echo from in XTO
so gr m the generalized linear model the
random progress GPN the gradient
boosting machines and deep learning so
that's from the most common algorithm
that you will find in other package
shown in our in Python in other
languages but we intervene audits from
scratch and we optimize it in Java so
this is a high-performance algorithm
although it's similar to what you saw in
other tools so we go I can show you how
to do this model in Xcode
sometimes you want to dipper and want to
find out more information about each
algorithm so if you go to this website
at plcs which is documents top xji so
you can find a lot more information
about h2o and h2o algorithms and
everything about the features in h0 you
can find from this single website for
example here if you click on the lessons
of GBM then you will show you more
information about GBM or is what it does
and what the limitation of GBM okay so
let's go back to that regression problem
so we're going to use the same the wine
quality data set again that we saw in
the first example so what we're trying
to do this time is to use the features
say on the left hand side got eleven
features about the wine so this
different characteristics of a wine and
then at the end we at the quality
this code is a number that and people
assigned to this wine so that if they
say from I think is it from three to
nine so creative pores and nine is the
highest quality so it assign quality to
do two different wines and record the
different catalystic of the wine so we
can use this features here to try to
protect a wine in the future so we can
use this like a simple predictive model
exercise okay so first of all in a
machine learning task you need to define
the features the feature is always so
before the it's the eleven features on
the left-hand side so in HTML you need
to tell them that I want to use all
these features so you can say I can use
other names of that table the data frame
excluding the last one excluding that
quality because if you can see that if I
exclude the quality column in there and
the rest will be the features that I
want to use in the modeling exercise so
this is the code that I use at the end
you have a simple it's here up telling
you about the names the column names of
the features that I want to use in this
model so and and then this is one of the
really common cards that you do for
machine learning you want to speed the
data into different parts it's because
if you use or data to train your model
you can fail fall into a problem call
overfitting so
can be you can memorize everything very
well in that training data set but the
model doesn't generalize to the future
problem to other data so what we wanted
to do some time is to separate just get
a whole out set for testing for
forfeiture for the violations and use
the rest for training and that's what we
do here is why I'm using X percent of
the data for the model training and pull
out 20% of that for further testing and
that's how we do it in XTO so we using
the speed and let's go Fame function in
Xcode and then you can you can certify a
ratio the weight of the first number is
f no project so h2 with a couch
automatically go to the rest of the
class percentage so you can just say our
IQ percent for training and then you
have to today's at 80% and 20% different
okay so far yeah some basic stuff so now
this is the the first algorithm that I
want to show you an elusive xgo GLM in
here so maybe you can't really see from
the screen maybe it's better on on on
your laptop so all you need to do first
in python is to from h2o we import the
functions for grm so that's the GMM
estimator you can see maybe on your
screen so and then you need to tell
actually what tough problems this is so
this is for questions so we use the
family as a guardian for for this
problem so if here is read for binary
classification or a problem you have a
specify a different distribution or
different family so once you define the
model and then you go to the using the
training functions you train with the
equals of features the feature is 211
the radio that we specify for this
training and then we look at the target
which is authorities of the wine that we
want to predict and we point to the data
frame that we use so it's a key percent
that we take out when we take out for
training today it's the minimum API to
do a CRM model in the next few so when
you execute that so when when you
execute this code it's not using Python
to do the computation it's going to talk
to HT or cluster in JVM and use the Java
to do those computations and then you
can get the result back to Python when
it's done
so for for machine learning problems so
we need something to measure the
performance so there are many metrics in
HDL that is already implement for
different problems so I'll just go and
pick one of the one of the metrics in
h2o so using the mean squared error so
just like if you have a low Earth then
it's a better model so all you do after
you train your model is that you can
just print out in Python you can just
type the lame or the screen blanket at
the model and it will get some basic
information about the model so it's like
a summary of the model you may not see
everything but this is like the order
metrics that we calculate based on the
model on the training data set but it is
looking at only looking at the training
leaders at some time it's not know
representative of the true performance
of the model so we need to do next is to
actually use this model and allow the
model performance on the whole chain of
centers that I set and that's what we're
trying to do in here so we're using the
model underscore performance function in
X 2 and then you point it to the test to
the frame and it would do the same
telemetric calculations using the same
using the model on the test data set and
it will Adam give you more metrics so
that's a way to look at okay how how how
good is in on unseen data set okay and
the final step so so once you have the
model what you want to do with the model
is mainly about protection so you can
now use a model to make detection so
this is only using the same test in a
frame but imagine it is it's like the
future is that so in the pipeline when
you have the new data coming into the
system you can convert that into the
actual to the frame and then use this
function to make some predictions so for
example this is a requesting problem so
it just give you some numbers so it is a
kind of Cajun problem that I will show
it on it will give you the predictor
label and the probability of different
card so the question is just a number
one column four numbers okay it's an
okay so far the simple GOM model yes to
make some prediction okay
so the next two scientists going to show
you the API for different algorithms
it's the same kind of theory using the
same that that the training is edge of a
key percent data but we're using
different algorithms so the first one
here on top is the random forest record
DLF it creates a bit recruited when I'm
forward so we can see the API there
again you have to import a function from
h2o you set up the model and that the
final point is that pump it it's the
same you just point to the X which is
the features wide the response or the
target and the defame the same applies
to GPM again you import a function of
GBM set the model and then you do dog
training after the model enemy will just
give you the model and finally we have
the same API for deep learning again you
import a function do the same thing but
that we're using different algorithm in
x0 to train your model in Java okay
okay so that is the basics for
regression models so it's any questions
over before I move on to a
classification problem you guys are
smart so you got no question at all all
right whoo okay so I want to do the same
basic stuff but this time on a different
data set this time I want to do it for a
classification problem so we move on to
the next notebook here but actually the
one tanks is no number for a the
classification basics so we're going
back to use the PATA Negra data at this
time so this time we want to predict
whether the passenger survived or not in
this charity so we you can see that the
column is the second month we mention
that this is like an integer when you
import the data into H 2 O so we're
going to do first is to convert that
column in from integer to categorical
value or theorem in Java so this is what
we do
I also promote and other things in
another column intercepts because of
class our saying that it is more
suitable for categorical value in self
integer so I converted two columns from
integer to categorical value so this is
and the cook to
to do that and then do a simple table
clown to see how many videos how many
unique values in different column so
then I also like hand packet some
features because I don't want to use all
features some more features you like the
passenger names or information that may
not help the model so I hand pick some
of the features from metadata set to
clear this model and to do that I just
create in polis in Python and just give
them the name of different column okay
and the same thing I did like the
Russian problem I spit into X percent
for training and 20 percent for
validation or testing okay so we move on
to the first I will come again so grm
again this time remember it's not for
real questions this time it's for binary
classification so it's that once you
import the model maybe on the screen
then you can see I'm adapt the model in
the family as binomial so this is like a
binary classification and family or the
seclusions so we have to define that so
XT understand I'm not doing a binary
classification instead of regressions
but the rest is almost identical so I
point to the features at this time the Y
the target is the survived column and
then you point to the same you execute a
code and you train the model in Xcode
JVM and so this time because it's a
different problem so we're using
different techniques or different
metrics to measure the performance so
one of the really common ways to measure
the performance of a cut vacation
problem it's look at the confusion
matrix in here so how many of you have
heard about a commercial matrix before
okay so Adam reacts in to explain a lot
so is like how you visualize the
problems in a matrix so you have the two
positives and the two negatives in one
diagonal and the false ones in the other
diagonal so what we want to do is to
optimize or to maximize the tool active
and the true for the positive in this
matrix
so that's what we got in Excel so so we
have to now we camp the model in GL and
model so we can print it out
so again summary again but this time you
also get the collusive matrix as the
result in summary at all because also we
have other metrics to to measure
classification like loss so we can also
see it from the table there there are
lots of different measures so we
automatically calculate a lot of
different metrics for you every time you
train your model or want to evaluate a
new model and then we can do the same
thing on the test set so we use the
model underscore performance features to
look at the model performance on the
different unseen tests to detect and
then we give you some results like that
and finally this is the time to make
prediction so say you're happy with this
gon model you want to make some
predictions so you do the same thing you
wanna to the research use the PDX
function in X 2 and this time you will
not only give you one single column for
the D'Amico wave it's time you give you
three columns the reason is that the
first column is the actual predator
class so it's either 0 or 1 so it
survived from 0 or 1 to cut but you also
get the probabilities for each card so
that is quite useful sometimes because
sometimes you may have a model that's
really really competent on some
predictions but sometimes a bit
uncertain on some in some situations so
these numbers will give you another way
to look at the protections so that I how
how competent you can field on different
connections okay so let's want to
calculate show you the same kind of API
for different algorithms so again we
start with venom forwards and the top
and GBM bottom so what you need to do
again is to import function set it up
and point to X Y X the features while
the target and the defame is always the
same but of course this is the basic
usage of h2o there are a lot more
arguments that I can use in those
algorithm to make it better so which I
will show you in the next session region
the 1 uses of x2
and again quickly about learning so you
just do the same thing
point to the deep learning functions and
make a prediction and that is the end of
the basic actual usage so the next
session will be more about tuning the
performance or make it better so making
one of the algorithm better on the
research if you want to take a break or
ask me any questions we can have like a
fireman inspect if that's okay with you
guys yeah okay
so let's have a five minutes back and
then you can also ask me any question
you need time okay okay so for example
can use the number of trees and trees so
you can give the exterior model more
time to train some more number of trees
when they build a model you can also
give an example on a sewer way which is
the the random set we sample weight of
different roads equally we have to
resample ways for different columns so I
put I put nope online which is 90
percent of that so every time we include
some of the randomness into the tree so
that actually helps keep the model to to
be more generalized to future data so
once you have the model from this
setting to visit my manual settings for
this GBM then again we can test the
model on on the unseen 10% research then
if you can see that this is allow
getting slightly better so we have a
lower MSE or mean square error this time
so which means the demand settings that
I put into that model actually worked on
this in this case so we have to reduce
the error a little bit but sometimes
it's not enough to only look at the test
set because maybe I just got lucky in
this case maybe I just got lucky with
this test dataset we want something some
extra measurements to help me to make
decisions whether I make the correct
settings on this model so we move on to
a technical code violations so how many
of you have heard about
cross-validation kpop theory okay great
so you probably know about it so the
idea is to that every time you train
your model you create a simple as more
whole data set so we can see the pond
table
from fro one two four five every time we
choose a random sample from that take it
out to use that for extra measurement on
the enginetech data set so we call it
the cross-validation and after that we
use the average of that to give you
another value to measure the performance
of the model on unseen data set so once
we have that we want to do that in H so
it's quite easy so all you need to do is
to include one more argument in that so
you can see maybe on the screen the
final argument is called nforce the
number of rows you have five so you can
do usually I do FIFO or if you don't
have enough time you can do three so
five or even ten or twenty if you have
more time so we could give you more
accurate measurements this time I use
five something that it would do the same
thing as I saw in on this club it will
create five different folds to do the
correlations so that's all you need in
hto so just define the number of n so I
moved to the training and in the backend
but I didn't change the setting for the
sample wage and a chrome sandwich so
this you should expect you have the same
performance on untested attach because I
didn't change anything in the settings I
only asked h2o to create a cross
validation for me to look at different
measurements so that's okay that so when
you print out the model you can see that
there's a and a matrix tables edge and
then top one is that it's average of the
MSE across the five cross-validation and
now if we go back to the summary table
we can start we have another value in
there for customizations so now we have
another measurement as a baseline so
that is from this point I want to
measure the cross-validation as well in
terms of performance of the model on
until attached so I have two
measurements one on the cross-validation
and one on the test attach everything
okay
so far yep so next step I want to do is
to include and the technique called a
stopping have you heard of sorting
before yeah so let me just explain it so
sometimes when you train the model long
enough say for example GPM the gradient
boosting machines if you have extended a
huge number of trees
memorize everything about the changes at
every course overfitting so you can see
that there's a the graph there you look
at the training layer that the error the
the mean square error because go down
all the way down to the day zero because
we're just trying to use the algorithm
to memorize everything happened in the
past but that may not generalize well on
an simulate such as you can see that on
the day like craft there so at some
point the performance on the test
dataset will deteriorate and we don't
want that so we want to find out that
sweet spot to where to stop that so we
want to train the model for too long we
want to stop that where we want to find
a switch what that the test performance
is just watch it that's perfect and then
before he goes to deteriorate and that's
why we want to do in in this step we
want to find a switch spot so all you
need to do in h2o is okay and look at
the screen is to include some extra
arguments to tell x0 that we want to do
a no stopping so we want to tell x2 oh I
want to look at the metric MSD which is
the mean square error in this case we
don't really look at fifteen ones so
meaning that every time we find a new
the best performance on a test that will
go for another fifteen wrong
fifteen treat in this case and see if
it's still go up four fifty after
sitting to it it will just go back to
the switch spot and stop there and use
that at the best model for that case so
that's what we have here and then so
once you you won this model and then we
just actually we just start looking at
the performance every time and once you
have final switch spot this time we
found that the crease number it's 155 so
that is a sweet spot that we want to
stop the the model here so that we is
using h2o2 this job and also
automatically for you in the background
to make sure that you can just get the
best model at that point in time so once
we have this model using stopping then
we can again look at the performance on
both coasts validations and at estimated
and now you can see that for both
measurements so for the cross-validation
measurement and the test that we both
count down a bit
Sadiq Khan down a bit so that is a good
good indication that this is working
because now you're not only looking at
one measurement you're getting both
measurement on correlations and tests so
that it's giving you more confidence
that this Senate is working on this
model okay if it okay so far yeah okay
so next step so I show you how to use
always stopping but that's only based on
the manual settings I gave so the menu
setting for example wage in the porn
lines and is the column sample weighting
0.99% but that's only based on know my
experience sometimes it doesn't work for
all that such we want to use h2o to
actually serve to a grid search and for
more options more combination of
different settings so that's what the
next step is about grid search I just
created a way simple table here for to
look at different options in sample
rates the sample weight for rows and
then we sample weight for columns but
you can see that even for like three
process in each options will give you a
total of nine combinations of my model
that you may have to search so imagine
that if you have a different strategy so
you want to expand the search page for
more so we want to include another
parameters in there then you can expect
that the search phase we go know
exponentially if you have a really
compact search space but let's look at a
small search great idea like nine models
in extra let's just go for them or in
extra so we need to do in EXO is the
talk that you can see on the screen is
to actually oh okay this is the search
space I have so three pounders for the
column
sample weight free for the sample weight
four rows I won't look at all of them so
I want to use the strategy of calcium
test mean the full free search of
everything that you have in that search
page and then you use the actual with
search function in next o2 to look at
the GBM model in this time so this time
when you execute a model it will do all
the things behind to look at different
so every time we change the parameters
in different settings based on the list
that you use a fighter and we compute
all different nine models for you and
give you the performance
the metrics for different settings then
you can now print out the table so if
you go to the next page and then you can
see that this is now giving you a more
no more evidence for you to design
weather which weather a setting is good
or not for this model and you can tell
from the the MSE term the mean square
error from this table so it is saying
that in this case we say that for the
column sample which we should use not
pollinate and for sample weight which is
you know point nine which is ninety
percent so that will give us the lowest
MSE in this case so that's good so now
I'm not using my own no experience to
judge whether this model is good or not
I'm using more evidence from from
different experiments in hto to tell me
more about the different settings and an
impact on this dataset so after that
again you can just extract the best
model and then you can use it and then
you can test again on the tab data set
and if you look at the table again we
much whether it's all this time so we
can to also reduce the mean square error
in correlations so as a test set
it is like step by steps to improve the
model so so of course so once you can
this workshop you don't have to go
through this every step know every time
you can just go to the final step but I
just want to show you the logic behind a
few additional features in XTO and how
they improve the performance on them on
the model okay so far any question okay
so okay so the next step here is it's
about the search phase how do we do the
search page so I'll talk about the grid
search so yep that's a question please
wait and that's Mike come out
yeah I dislike yes and that one so I was
surprised with the mean squared error
and the on the folds was higher than the
mean squared error on the test set
consistently okay because they're not
exactly the same thing so that this
correlation is looking at the go back
you here so the test and the
cross-validation there is that it's
based on the random resembling inside
the training that I set so we're not
looking exactly the same data when we do
the cross-validation and attach so you
could get luckier on the test at
attached which is the tournament said
that we we took out earlier and you may
get a worse performance on the
cross-validation but the point is to
compare step by step when you add
different features in extra to make it
better
that it with used to error in both case
and that's the rest of the main theory
of this so you don't have to compare
them now like Apple to Apple they're not
Apple to Apple but you compare to the
previous features that you add to the to
the step it's actually okay no no the
test is a let me just go back to so the
test is before we start everything
because we started to cross validation
we take out two numbers and just leave
it no forever right that and the
correlation is within that 80% so that
that's why they're not able to Apple
comparison any more questions before I
move on okay let's go back to
yeah so we talked about this good shot
so this one is a simple one with nine
different combinations so why if we want
to expand this no search base to a bit
bigger so this is what what we want to
do in this situation
so now I want to include another process
in there is the depth of different trees
of the trees you can do decision trees
you can go with it some depth so I want
to search another PDF so three five and
seven step add into another complexity
to the search page so it makes about
twenty-seven combinations in total so
enter three times of the original search
page but say okay this is a total search
you can wanna quickly even is 2007
combinations but what if you have a much
more compact search page and then you
have enough power on a vector that you
may want to reduce the size of search to
a lumber that you can handle so maybe it
could be a time okay put a number of
models that you could handle with your
hardware in a within a certain time
frame that's what we're doing here you
want to throw of the channel seven
combinations we only want to search for
nine combinations for example this case
I don't want to look for all of the
combinations I want to take a random
nine combinations of that search page
and to the same current research in h2o
and tell and see if I can find a better
solution to this problem so that's the
code in there you can see it on the
screen and then so once we do that then
XTO will just randomly based on a random
six pegs nine of those combinations from
the Chinese seventh and do the same
research that we saw before so this time
you can see that we have on the first
table there there are three columns of
different settings so we have the sample
wage for columns simple wage for the
rows as well as the max F so this is
getting so it's a bigger space than
before so we're expanding the search to
more the bigger tertiary and see if we
can find better solutions in that search
space and we did so we can see that now
we can compare the new metrics on the
zip across wide regions and then
on the test set and compare it that with
the previous full search but that
remember that spook research is based on
a smaller search space this one or those
who have the same kind of nine model
research but we're looking at a much
bigger search base in here because we
include the max staff in this search
grade so we managed to find a better
solution in this time so we also videos
both metrics in this case
okay so everyone okay so far so that's
the random search so this is about the
most technical way to do in the data
mining compositions so you don't have
time to go through all the combinations
that you want to search in the search
page this is the most particular a to do
a tracker search on some good settings
for your model in a reasonable amount of
time so please remember to use this step
so when you are moving on from this
workshop to your own problems use these
steps for you to get some good settings
for your data okay so the last one is
the more advanced even more once I need
to combine different models together so
the previous step is only based on one
algorithm so the GBM the gradient
boosting algorithm but for for
determining competitions like cargo you
want to combine different models of
rhythm algorithms but like you have one
to have a better larger diversity of the
models to capture different things in
the data and then combine them together
quickly
so we create features in h0 cost and
sample so this is the next report now so
is the three be so regressions and
samples so many digits based on the work
from arendelle everything down so you
did a PhD on stacking model so this is
one of the well a useful way to improve
the performance now quickly without
doing a lot of feature engineering and
this also work from for Mario's modules
if you know him he is the top tackler so
it was the former number one color color
in in this composition in this platform
so we also turn EXO so thankfully we
have him to bring his experience in the
h2o to improve this stacking as well so
he he has his own software cost at next
so he's a really experienced in stacking
model so that actually worked for him
and he actually won a lot of
competitions you think stacking so this
is one of the tablet that you may want
to use it if you want to join the cargo
come kitchen so back into the h2o so how
do we do the stacking simply in h2o so
first of all I want to show you the same
thing that we have done before so just
to a random research on GPM this time so
using the research to look for a good
model of the best model using a GPM
algorithm and then just use that for the
future and the next two step is almost
the same but I'm on or using I'm using a
different algorithm this time so using
random forests a time you can see that
the settings and the search space on
different browsers are different because
the underlying idea is the same so to a
random good search for this algorithm
and get the best model for that and then
move on to your next algorithm so next
I'll go for me so depending I go from
h2o so again you will provide a
different search base back to a random
research and get the best model so now I
have three best model from the three
different one and research I want to use
this step and sample function in h2o to
stack them together quickly and to give
me a much better performance than before
so that's what the main API for model
stacking in h2o so you first of all you
you list the model together so queerness
in Python that's the list of the model
the best photo from the ppb's research
to the best GBM model the best random
forest model and the best divining model
so once you have that you can you can
set up the set ensemble which is the
second part of the code on maybe on your
screen and then you do a training
function again similar to other training
concerns to put X features y equal to
target and then the same and we do all
our caper sucking in the back end so you
don't really see anything now
complicated in in this in this
environment you just see running
everything in the back end but is off
doing some really sophisticated stacking
in the back end and EXO so we shouldn't
use the cross validation results from
different models that they become new
features and then we stack them together
like a new American level chain better
training on those features and that
would give you if you can see that from
the table here
better Msgr MSD comparing with the best
model of each algorithm so once we have
that we can go back to the table so we
didn't do the correlations measurement
this time but we can see that the
performance on the test set is again
better than all previous steps so this
is some of the way that you can do with
your data set so when you put in h0
import data set we can train different
models and connect them together quickly
using this code ok so any questions so
far this is the example for questions
yes oh not yet but we are looking at
more different ways to export more
informations from this example example
so for now understand what you mean so
we say ok how different is the album
from GPM the model of GBM the contribute
to do that Enza boat and Venom forward
and deepening that we can if you can
imagine the first step we want to try to
do is to simplify the step so everything
is like in the back end but the next
step here is to keep user more ability
to extract information out of that that
process so that would be the next
version maybe a future version before
now just a simple training exercise to
get to get everything together but if
you can do it memory if you want to do
it manually what I need to do is to
extract the cross validation protections
from different algorithm and to your
meta training yourself and that you can
have more no more sage or more
informations about which one whichever
from contribute more to the final
ensamble but that's the many way to do
it we don't want the user to do that for
now but in the future we want to have
more functions to know exporter
information ok
any more questions before I move on to
the next number yep oh sorry Anna - wait
for it so you suspect three models and
and you got too low you got the best
performance and would it be possible to
that if you stack only two models that
the performance might be better yeah so
that is the good thing about h2o is
easier for you to not change that so for
example if you want to just choose two
models all you need to do here is to
change the niche on the top so you can
see that it's the list but you only need
to do if you have you like if you have
like ten models or something then you
would check like ten models stack ten
models when I intellij yeah and then you
have to check all the combinations yeah
so what we can do in notated programming
language you can do a look to go who app
or you can just believe in extra because
the way that we do the matter training
is the same so it's kind of a feature
selection in the same time so we're
using the method learning to look at
which model two features from this
different algorithm to contribute more
so that kind of automatically done but
of course I understand at some time if
you exclu some of the models you may get
you to a better performance but you can
do it quickly by just changing the list
in there using a for loop all the ways
to do it and then actually we just look
at smaller section of the model cake you
get the same performance metrics and
then you 0 okay maybe it is better okay
any more questions
Louis okay so I just want to move on to
the same kind of principles but this
time it's on a different problem so we
go back to the Titanic so it's a binary
classification problem so again is it
new Kuipers and notebooks or for P&N
classification and samples so I won't go
into much detail but it is same kind of
principles I want to Train TPM mode or
to gradient boosting model on the
connector set and I want to train
running forward again on that same
method using when and research so now I
have a two good model so one good GBM
and one
random forest model I want to combine
them but this time I want to create a
model for classifications so we can see
that maybe on your screen that you can
this is the same kind of API to do the
stack and Sam Bowie next row but we are
using a different metric this time we're
using a you see two area and the curve
this time that is higher it's better so
you can see that in the final table that
the individual model will give you about
x1 eggs on the point ax and 0.9 the
final one is a bit improvement based on
the combination of two models so back to
the same question in education and math
so you can have ten hundreds of models
and two when you do an example this is
only to use a toy example with two
models in here put it in Turkish you can
use h2o to give you more models so you
form a quick search you can extract all
the model from like research will give
you ten twenty fifty models from
different algorithms and then you can
compile everything together as long as
you can create at least to capture all
the names of the models and XTO just go
through all the features in those of
generators from those balls and give you
the second sample at the end or quickly
in a simple API like this ok so that it
really is the stacking for
classification so if you want to tune it
you can just expect the same step like I
saw you in the question problem so we
can use close relations or stopping and
research running do search of food
research and apparently the set and
tumble to tune it so this is suing you
deter to the final step so usually if
you after this workshop you don't have
to go through all the steps again again
you can just go through the maybe the
final step using the set ensemble and
usually that would give you a really
really good model know for for any
purpose okay so final thing I want to
show it so I'm showing you I will use
audit on your computer on a single
computer some time we want to say you
want to deploy X show in the car because
you want to go to maybe Amazon with the
Google car from or much know a previous
server or much powerful machines with
more CPU code so all you to do is to
deploy h2o using the Java command so I
can show you life in here so first of
all you can go back to XTO download
let's get the pure Java version of hto
extracted on on that server on the
undercut there could be a next server
could be a Windows or other platform
server as long as you have Java 1.7
above install on the machines and this
will work so let me just show you how to
do that so for example I just download
that zip utility to the latest version
of xeo so when you download that is a
zip file that I can put on anywhere so I
put on the desktop here and that's the
folder that I extract out so when you
open that you see a sister or is inside
that zip file so all you need to do if
you can see here you need this jar so
actual structure is the the file that
you need to create a Custer weather on a
computer or weather on a Remo machines
so let's imagine if this is like a
custard on the cloud so if I open it
terminal let me just make it bigger okay
can you guys see it yeah lovely so so
it's like go back to this case here you
see that the command here is Java having
jar and an actual doctor ah so if I do
that here so Java must pixel jar so when
I execute this command it will create a
Custer so the actual cutter on on this
machine so for example now is on my
desktop or my laptop but imagine if you
do the same thing in a remote in in the
cloud then you can have the the power in
the car with XTO on so but how do you
connect to that cow so you need I P
address and the port so what I need to
do is look at the information here
because I change the font size so you
can see it clearly but usually it is the
IP address and the port is 5 4 3 2 1 so
what we can do to do to correct you this
server here is going back to this page
Sergi so once you have that cutter now
deported somewhere on a cloud all you
need to do supplies to actual is the IP
address of that other machines so in in
Python you after you import external
module this time you use actual connect
command so you supply the IP address of
that and then it will use it we use a
connection to connect a from your
machine to that actual cursor in a car
so you can utilize that more power from
a cloud to do much bigger problem and
that's how we do it a cure in the car
even okay so far yes
so actually what is the difference
between using like running a Jupiter
notebook in in a multi-core machine
server and then using that particular IP
address in my machine because that also
uses the same power right so what is the
what is the difference between using
kind of h2o with multiple core
possibilities and running a jupiter
notebook in a multi-core machine and
then using the same ip address to run
the jupiter notebook service in my
machine to use the h2 in my machine
oh so say if you have to beta now over
this departure on the machines you don't
have to do this step which is like for
your machine so if you want to use to be
the owner on your own machines but you
want to connect to the actual cutter
that is in the cow then you do this step
so if you already have Jupiter of
departure in any cows you can just do
textual initiate so if other IP address
we'll just do the initiation in that cow
then your two paternal poke in a cow can
automatically detect that that actual
cutter in a cow okay yeah so this is
only for if you want to use your own
machines away from the cows to do that
so that is different ways to go into X 0
o 3 operations looking which I want to
show you that now so now is extra cutter
here on my laptop I just want to quickly
show you how you can connect it to that
castor
using your web browser so because it's
my own machine so it's localhost or
127.0.0.1 simple but for example if I
want to get the data you can just value
to say this it's the same kind of wine
quality CS we use been using you select
that you upload to that and this will
give you some options to change the type
so for example this is all numeric so
it's okay but for example maybe if you
want to change whether the quality
column two categorical you can change it
to eat them here so that's something
that you can ask your colleague or your
friends if they want to only use Python
or now to do with actual they can use a
web browser to do the same thing then
just pass that then this CSV is imported
to the memory of actual cluster and you
can also do this very quick like a
visualization here so for example we can
look at some of the columns here see the
execution of this column so this is a
way to quickly like prototyping some of
the data set into your actual cluster
and let's have a look around later on so
there's this one way is to use h2o so
you're saying that if if I'm actually
running the h2o dodge are in in for
example like a 40 core cluster particle
machine and I'm actually using that
particular localhost in my machine then
here I can actually make use of those 40
core course right
so you surprise a different IP address
so you actually use the IP address in
the cloud this time to connect to the
machines and then you have had the power
of that cow service or folio of machines
so we can do the same thing you can
upload the data set into the memory so
for then you have a good neighbor
connection so that all that and all
computations is done in the cow with the
40 cause inside of your computer and do
I need to SSH into that particular or
just
the h2o clitoris is actually good enough
to connect with it yeah so all you need
first of course is the Java so Java 1.7
above or open SDK so open JDK sorry if
you have that as a base requirement in
that in the Calcutta that's all you need
and then you can download excuse the zip
file that I'll show you before how to
that cluster unzip it and this Java
having jar h2o jar and I will just
initiate the custard in the car yeah
thank you please I'm a little bit
confused about terminology you using so
you say cluster the whole time but the
examples actually show a single
multi-core machine yeah can I get say 25
40 core machines and run h2o on that yes
so what I'm showing here this is a
cutter in on its own it is a cuts are
using my own laptop so a virtual call or
a quad-core CPU so egg vertical and I
assign some memory to it but if you want
to use multiple cuts there so maybe
another laptop here so if I have another
top I can initiate this ratio again here
I wanted to do is to provide a list of
IP address so I have to address this one
and this one
and they can communicate each other and
they will share the CPU power a CPU
resource and the memory so you're using
maximizing the resource that you have
so at home I do like multiple laptops
together in the home network
so for that you have a good connection
with them they can just part custom in
different laptops and work together
that's beautiful of actual speed if you
say all you've got to do is to give it a
list of IP addresses does that imply
that the local machine you're working on
does the role of the master mode let's
know so in actual that no specific
master lock
so it's unlike a job spark everyone not
share the like a share the data and our
function a so they're using the same
kind of the API that you use in Python
and now it's the same like the single
cluster but when you execute it it will
automatically disappear the job to
upload to all different machines that is
that kind of accept and you don't have
to the user we do not have to specify
which one we do that one which when we
do the other job you just automatically
do it in the backend so you're handing
handling down the list so all note can
communicate with all other no yeah okay
can also say that maybe you can kind of
say that your your control your the
desktop or your laptop is count the
master to execute the command but that's
in the interface to talk to actual cut
that to do to do some work but it's not
actually a master in in a way as a tip
or spark okay it's it's like the third
thing so we should start moving to the
right so I will just arrived at quickly
and just a feel most like that's it
so a quick recap
so in this workshop I just want to show
you how to use a co the basic usage and
some advanced usage so hopefully that
after this workshop you can start X your
cutter from Python you know how to
import some data at CSV or from internet
into x2 and then you can do some basic
transformation train some regression
model cut extension model improve the
performance using different techniques
in actual and if you want to use much
more power of powerful machines in a cow
you can do that hopefully and the
somewhere here is that I'll show you how
to use experience different function h
do to improve the performance step by
step and if you want more information
remember this is the address
I want to remember so it documents the
OCS 0 AI then you can find more
tutorials ampuls from from that webpage
there are also more ongoing stuff of
actual so I will be here around for the
weekend so if you want to ask me about
other things happening a textual a
schema shot
so finally thank you for having having
me again in Berlin I will have to be
here if you want to contact me this is
my contact info you can also find all
the information for the period on the
future meetups of exposing that cylinder
if you want to search questions
on stackoverflow please let me remind
you that use h2o attack in South x2 0
because if you put h20 some time and get
2 wrong questions so x2 oh it's attack
that you need for that overflow so thank
you very much
[Applause]